réunion extraordinaire d'urgence à l'onu
les 196 193 pays membres vont débattre
de la guerre en ukraine d'ici quelques
minutes on court trop emmanuel
saint-martin en direct depuis new york
réunion extraordinaire donc que peut-on
en attendre
when you're extraordinaire parce que
c'est une procédure qui avait été créé
au moment de la guerre de corée en 1950
qui est employée très rarement c'est la
dixième fois dans l'histoire des nations
unies et il s'agit effectivement mais
finalement cette résolution qui a été
bloquée au conseil de sécurité par la
russie il s'agit de la faire adopter
cette fois par l'assemblée générale
alors les conséquences ne seraient pas
les mêmes annoncé qu'une résolution
adoptée par l'assemblée générale n'a pas
le même poids juridique n'a même pas de
portée juridique réel en réalité face à
bas en comparaison avec ce que le
conseil de sécurité peut adopter
néanmois il s'agit finalement de compter
les voir un peu un pour les américains
et leurs alliés occidentaux qui présente
cette résolution de voir qui se met au
côté des occidentaux qui reste aux côtés
des russes qui s'abstient c'est cela qui
va être le plus intéressant à observer
dans ce décompte des voix qui va
commencer dans quelques minutes ici avec
un point de référence finalement c'est
une résolution alors selon une autre
procédure mais une résolution sur le sol
sur l'ukraine et la russie qui avaient
été adoptées en 2014 lors de la première
invasion de la russie en ukraine et à ce
moment là on avait eu sans voix en
faveur de cette résolution condamnant la
russie et 11 contre les autres s'étant
abstenus ou n'ayant pas participé au
vote on va voir donc si ce réservoir
assez important
d'abstention va diminuer ou pas
évidemment l'écho international de la
crise cette fois-ci de la guerre en
ukraine cette fois ci est beaucoup plus
important qu'il n'a été en 2014 donc les
occidentaux notamment ça ne s'attendent
à voir le camp d'aidé pour des états en
faveur de cette résolution augmenté mais
on le saura dans quelques heures
maintenant ici un peu moins même à
l'issue de ce vote avec une résolution
une réunion de l'assemblée générale qui
commence à l'instant où on se parle
alors imaginez
là il y a une minute de silence à
l'ouverture justement de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu où vous vous trouvez
l'onu doit s'y montrer qu'elle allait à
la hauteur de cette guerre la plus
importante selon beaucoup depuis la fin
de la guerre froide comment frapper fort
alors que vous l'avez dit la russie va
opposer des vétos à chaque proposition
en fait
au niveau du conseil de sécurité oui
alors il n'y a pas de veto dans
l'assemblée générale ce qui explique
pourquoi on est devant l'assemblée
générale on peut avoir un vote mais
évidemment avec des conséquences moins
lourdes juridiquement disons ou pas de
conséquence du tout juridique sûr à la
suite d'une résolution de l'assemblée
générale il s'agit avant tout de montrer
effectivement l'union de la communauté
internationale d' essayer de peser sur
la russie ça reste symbolique largement
comme beaucoup de ce qui se passe ici à
l'assemblée générale évidemment les
nations unies faut quand même le
rappeler à chaque fois qu'on parle de
ces sujets c'est un groupe d'états
souverains et finalement c'est la
souveraineté des nations la souveraineté
des états qui l'emportent et lorsqu'un
état comme la russie qui a le veto au
conseil de sécurité ne ne veut rien
entendre ne veut pas venir à la table de
négociation par exemple où vous souhaite
un peu s'imposer par la force il y à peu
finalement que l'onu puisse faire alors
ça c'est évidemment sur la résolution du
conflit elle même et sur sur la
diplomatie à côté de ça il ya évidemment
les actions humanitaires qui est un rôle
important de l'onu le soutien aux
réfugiés l'aide aux états qui sont en
train d'accueillir un million de
réfugiés qui sont arrivés cds ces
derniers jours en pologne notamment mais
aussi dans les autres pays voisins de
l'ukraine là évidemment c'est un rôle
essentiel des nations unies on va en
parler dans les dans les heures qui
viennent ici
merci beaucoup emmanuel saint-martin
évidemment on va sur avec vous cette
section cette session extraordinaire
d'urgence qui se tient donc actuellement